[Música]
porque hoy en este espacio en directo a
nos vamos hasta Honduras para hablar con
nuestra corresponsal Kenia Torres las
Naciones Unidas confirmaron que
acordaron con el gobierno hondureño el
envío de un grupo de expertos para
establecer una comisión internacional
contra la corrupción y la impunidad la
instalación de esta comisión había sido
una de las promesas de campaña del
actual presidenta
Xiomara Castro Kenia que se instaurará
exactamente en esta comisión Que hará la
comisión en Honduras
Hola Cómo estás Te saludo en efecto Esta
es una comisión que se instalará en
Honduras con el objetivo máximo y
objetivo principal de luchar contra la
impunidad en el país recordemos que la
presidenta
Xiomara Castro basó la campaña
precisamente que la llevó al poder
permitiendo esto y prometiendo combatir
la corrupción con la ayuda de la ONU es
por eso que empezó a hacer las gestiones
el pasado mes de noviembre luego en
diciembre viajó justamente a la sede de
las Naciones Unidas donde firmó un
memorándum de entendimiento y ya hoy en
el país hay un clima Pues de muchísima
satisfacción luego de que el
subsecretario general de las Naciones
Unidas para Europa Asia central y las
Américas Jean camiros lab
en su cuenta de Twitter que se acordó
pues enviar un equipo de expertos que
estaría llegando a Honduras en las
próximas semanas así que para las
autoridades los funcionarios del
gobierno Este es un paso trascendental
en Procura justamente de luchar contra
la corrupción e impunidad en el país
Bueno quería pero porque Hemos llegado
al punto de que se tenga que instaurar
una comisión de este tipo en Honduras y
perdón O sea Hemos llegado a este punto
pero la ONU pide garantías Por qué y qué
garantías aporta Honduras
es que recordemos que recientemente en
el gobierno anterior
por mandato de la oea se instaló acá un
organismo parecido
y justamente se trataba de la Maxi que
fue expulsada del país debido a que
empezó a tocar muchos intereses de alto
funcionario o sea del gobierno diputados
del Congreso Nacional que fueron
llevados hasta la justicia hay un caso
emblemático por ejemplo en la
judicialización de una ex primera dama
del país que fue llevada a la cárcel
precisamente por las gestiones de la
Maxi luego la presidenta Castro enarboló
justamente esa bandera durante su
campaña y ahora pues prácticamente será
una realidad con la llegada de la Sisi
al país que pide justamente tener
Independencia
imparcialidad autonomía
eh condiciones que Honduras está
dispuesta a dárselas